all right joining us now is jennifer say
the former brand president of levi's who
famously left one million dollars on the
table
over her values jennifer good to have
you on tonight um now you left san
francisco last year so you can't be
surprised about what happened this week
with those three school board members
being thrown out of office
but are you surprised that so many
democrats now are speaking openly even
to members of the media about what
finally broke them
well i will say i'm not surprised that
the school board was recalled um you
know it's a campaign that was started
about a year ago i know some of the
folks that started it i am surprised it
was this decisive i mean
it was 70 30.
so you know that is surprising to me and
the reason it's surprising is i was
outspoken about school closures in san
francisco since march of 2020 and i
certainly felt like i was
in the significant minority but what
this says to me is that there was a
silent majority of parents that were
incredibly frustrated outraged that
schools were closed for seven months and
and they showed up and they voted in the
special election to recall in a really
truly decisive manner and i think
this is causing people to rethink party
alignment you know for me
it's not even about party i i'm gonna
vote for candidates that support the
causes that i care about i'm an
independent now that i got to colorado
i'm going to vote for the candidates you
know i'm not going to pledge loyalty to
any particular party i'm going to vote
for candidates that connect with me and
support the causes that matter to me
was it more than just the school
closures
did did
the things that motivated the voters to
turn out in such you know a large
percentage to recall these candidates uh
recall these members
were they annoyed by some of the other
bit of focus that the board had during
this time like renaming a bunch of
schools and
and that kind of stuff was that did that
play into it as well
oh a hundred percent um i mean i was
calling in to school board meetings they
lasted seven eight nine hours um i often
got bored and gave up
but they didn't even talk about getting
schools open until the last half hour
they'd spent hours and hours on renaming
schools
okay maybe valid maybe not but certainly
not in the middle of a crisis when
schools have been closed for six months
eight months nine months a year and kids
are really suffering
so you know they just showed no urgency
on the matter and it's a true
dereliction of duty they're elected by
the people of san francisco they are
responsible for the children
and they are responsible to the families
in san francisco
but
that is not who they answered to they
were answering to the teachers unions
there was they were enormously haughty
and the unions really were calling the
shots across the country in a lot of
states not not every school district
but a lot in the states that refused to
open
and you saw this repeatedly that the
sort of diversity equity inclusion
new curricula was being
kind of
shoehorned in during this period of
uh you know remote learning and teachers
at home and some teachers in but that
was a real opportunity i think a lot of
uh activists
thought they had because everyone was so
overwhelmed with the virus we can do
this other stuff do you do you find that
to be the case
you know i think the naming of the
schools was such a flash point because i
mean it was just absurd
uh the rationale for renaming was wrong
in many instances
it was an insane number um you know they
were renaming dianne feinstein
elementary she's a sitting senator like
her or not we just elected her you know
our state had just elected her so it's
crazy it just doesn't
it just doesn't it didn't make sense i i
think i i really do think it was a
referendum on the closures and the lack
of focus on getting schools open and the
just intractability i i think that was
the driver
absolutely and you know i know a ton of
people there still i don't know a single
person that didn't vote to recall
and i will say this about about teachers
i i know a ton of teachers who are also
pushing for open schools so i i don't
think it's a uniform bunch you know i
know a lot of teachers who saw the harms
um but were afraid to speak out and go
against what you know the the position
the union was officially taken but
eventually the voters
yeah eventually there are a lot of great
teachers that's why that's teachers and
now i have a lot of teachers in my
family and i completely i have a lot of
teachers in my family and i totally
agree with you
but this was a bridge too far and we'll
see where this goes from here we're
going to be anxiously following it but
jennifer you stood with your principals
and you left big money on the table and
we really appreciate your you're joining
us tonight thank you